once celebrated as a Liberation party
that fought against racial segregation
in recent years South Africa's governing
African National Congress has been
riddled by corruption and criticism
it's the party of respected Global and
African leaders such as Oliver tumbo and
Nobel Peace Prize Laureate Nelson
Mandela
28 years into democracy the anc's facing
increasing condemnation for poor
leadership and governance
since Mandela subsequent presidents Tabo
and Becky and Jacob Zuma were recalled
or forced to resign current president
Sil ramaphosa is facing similar pressure
in a scandal involving the theft of
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
his game farm the anc's reputation for
many is in tatters kleptocracy nepotism
card rate deployment from the very
beginning of the ANC government which
then became a norm within the party and
within the higher echelons of government
so even when people are found to have
sallied their their their their their
their record as it were they still
continue to be deployed as members of
the ANC and as trusted members of the
ANC and that's what's led to rampant
corruption a poorly performing economy
record high unemployment and energy
crisis and a multitude of fraud scams
have frustrated South Africans the party
won the first Democratic elections in
1994 with a 60 two percent majority that
dropped to 57 in the last polls support
for the anc's been in Decline for years
some voters have protested against the
ANC by staying away from the polls
others have abandoned the governing
party and voted for the opposition the
Democratic Alliance and economic freedom
fighters dominate opposition voices
while their combined support of almost a
third of Voters can't be ignored an ANC
parliamentary majority is often
protected its embattled leaders
the ANC needed money and the people
who supported the ANC saw money as being
something that they could get their
hands on so the solution was
you could relatively easily do what you
wanted and get whatever tenders you
wanted provided you gave to Caesar a
portion of it and kept a portion for
yourself
and The Rock began thus
this weekend the party will hold an
elective conference to choose a
president and other senior figures
supporters hope the new leadership will
revive the party but for many South
Africans it's the same old faces with
the same old scandals family Al Jazeera
Johannesburg